when the NASA special program ended the
remaining three spacious had only flown
25 33 and 39 times respectively which is
not even half of their expected flights
that 400 not to mention the NASA didn't
even have another launch vehicle so why
didn't Asus top lucky space shows and
what have they been doing for the last
eight years
make sure to grow until the end to find
out welcome to hurry saw breeze there's
five main reasons that NASA stopped the
space shuttle program starting with
finances in one sentence the space
shuttle program was simply way too
expensive for NASA to continue it never
became the low-cost reusable solution
that they were looking for and every
single time they wanted launch it it
would cost an extra five hundred million
dollars to put that all in perspective
their yearly budget is only twenty 1.5
billion dollars and they had a total of
135 launches that means that they ended
up spending 67 point five billion
dollars on just recurring in launching
piece which is over three years budget
the total cost of the space shuttle
program was about 196 billion dollars
which is almost 10 years of funding and
during the same time period they were
also building the International Space
Station which also required billions of
dollars the total cost of the
International Space Station was 150
billion dollars and while NASA didn't
pay all of this they paid a pretty
significant chunk and at the same time
they were also launching several smaller
satellites around Earth the space
shuttle program the International Space
Station and small satellites around
Earth
almost cost NASA upwards of 20 years of
full budget is consuming most NASA's
budget and there was very little left to
return to her moon or launch Rovers on
to Mars the space shuttle program was
simply not financially sustainable
there was also pressure from the
government to move on President George
Bush announced that to return to the
moon and explore Mars and I would really
like a 11 billion dollars from the next
five years of funding over on to this
but they would only be given about Billy
knows
career north accommodated for more work
but nearly is same budget NASA had to
sacrifice something big and the obvious
choices were either the International
Space Station or a space shuttle program
but the International Space Station was
much more recent and had better future
prospects in space shuttle program and
so the space shuttle program had to go
if they really wanted to it probably
could have budgeted better accommodated
for all three of these tasks but
developing space technology always takes
longer and much more money than expected
so this was definitely the smart choice
also money wasn't the only problem there
was also a lack of manpower there was a
very limited pool of people who had
expertise in spaceflight operations and
there was an even small amount of people
what expertise in human spaceflight
operations nothing was that most of
these people already worked at NASA I
found a space shuttle program or the
International Space Station thus to
embark on these news tasks given by the
government that they required space
shuttles was a clear choice to shut down
a space shuttle program and redirect
those people over onto new programs
this way the reallocation of the budget
wouldn't hurt the International Space
Station also NASA's Space Shuttle
program didn't meet expectations at
first they thought that they could
launch a new space shuttle every single
week they were really looking for a
low-cost launch system whose development
costs could be cruelly reproved by
freaking access to space but by the mid
1980s it was clear that 52 missions here
was simply unrealistic and a lower the
max2 24 not only was the mission can't
release by over 50% but he had other
severe issues the Fonda's and the
spatula was 20% over the initial
specified weight this made it impossible
for them to launch US Air Force's
payloads at the polar orbit like
originally anticipated
also this officials made engineers
highly complex and maintenance intensive
this resulted in extensive inspection
time after each flight and made the
turnaround time even longer
several more setbacks made turnaround
time even longer and that
didn't accomplish many of its original
goals its launch rate peaked at nine in
1985 an average of four point five over
the whole program this is nowhere close
to 24 much less 52 they were way off the
hypothetical schedule and there were
several disappointments along the way
there was also major risks in launching
these space shuttles of the fact that
had to oven are completely gone and to
be honest it was unlikely the remaining
three would each get to one her space
missions and so for safety reasons it
was better to just stop the program on
January 28 1986 the space shuttle
Challenger blew up just 73 seconds after
launching this is because the o-ring
seals were not able to sustain the
really cold temperatures and this killed
the entire crew including seven people
and a year before President Bush made
the announcement to be Alec Kidd NASA's
budget on February 1st 2003 special
Columbia broke apart upon reentry
killing seven more crew members this was
caused by a small gouge on the left wing
that absorbed too much heat as it was
evident even the smallest of things
could lead to fatal consequences and the
main problem was that NASA officials
didn't even know that these small issues
would cause fatal consequences as a
result these problems simply could not
be anticipated and it was just a matter
of time before another tragedy occurred
so do today inherent risk of space
exploration it was good for NASA to end
off on a good note
because issues were to happen in 1970s
they definitely would have continued to
explore because there was a lot more
things to explore but by 2011 they'd be
consistent in launching specials for the
last 30 years and they always had a crew
at the international space station at
all times
as a result the space shuttles were
simply just vehicles to reach the
international space station there was
simply not that they have a purpose to
continue launch space shadows NASA had
already completed extensive research on
the effects of microgravity on the human
body and they could continue to do
research by simply sending their crew
members through shuttles of other
countries on top of this space X was
launching their own
rockets at this time all those rockets
failed at first they did eventually
succeed and Boeing was also embarking on
similar work space X NASA could save
billions of dollars and a lot of
manpower by offloading the
transportation of astronauts into space
on to private companies in other
countries they have started to see
diminishing returns after 40 years of
constant exploration frankly this
meaningless for NASA to continue to
launch space shuttles when there's other
ways for them to send their astronauts
into space and this way they can focus
onto other new work so what in the world
is NASA doing today well they're not
sitting around they've actually been
developing and launching several Rovers
exploratory devices to other planets and
asteroids for example the insight Mars
rovers that explore the inside of Mars
and the first astra return mission land
round asteroid in august of 2018 and it
is set to return in 2023 they are also
working to design a black experimental
planes called explains this includes low
boom flights which could open the door
to supersonic flights over land they
also have advanced solar electrical
ocean deep space navigation new green
propellants and in space manufacturing
and assembly which will all aid
deep-space exploration
and of course there's Mars exploration
President Trump just recently authorized
nineteen point five billion dollars in
funding for NASA and it's been a
longtime goal for NASA to land
astronauts on Mars in the 2030s and
right now they're looking at 2033 so
clearly it's quite a while from now well
eventually we will get there NASA space
shuttle program was a revolutionary
program that made it possible to reuse
space shuttles for space exploration
however the space shuttle program was
not as good as originally expected and
there are several issues along the way
not to mention the inherent risk in
repeatedly relaunching these shuttles
not only did not lose to space shuttles
which cost some billions of dollars but
14 crew members lost their lives with
mounting pressure from the government to
move on and
diminishing returns especially due to
the International Space Station the most
logical decision was to end the space
shuttle program in order to redirect
money and manpower and most importantly
avoid risk and that is exactly what NASA
did but that doesn't mean NASA is done
and they were actually aiming big to
reach Mars in 2033 but despite all of
this the space shuttle program was and
will always be a major step in space
exploration that's all I have for you
guys and NASA make sure coming down
below what company you would like me to
cover next also if you guys like to get
the message drop a like and consider
subscribing you can you'd like to see
more videos just like this one better
than sorry pal see us on that
[Music]